yeah dude dude
I didn't even know you had one on your
neck
[Music]
welcome back to uh amazing episode of
Hot Seat today we have in the hot seat
Mr Sub and Choi
so uh in case you're not familiar with
how these episodes go we're just gonna
ask you some increasingly hot questions
we're gonna start with a very cold
question from Bart take it away
if you had to stuff
caterpillars into themselves
how many do you think you can fit into
one
realistically five like a Russian doll
like a Russian doll of caterpillar yeah
but one has to fit like into the other
one perfectly yeah that's a lot
perfectly
two caterpillars fit another
caterpillars
female
[Laughter]
what gives you so much confidence you
said five like that you didn't even
think about it
um well first of all they're squishy so
you shove one in but make sure the one
that's outside is in a nice little layer
of hard layer tape them around open it
up squish them tape them around
that just sounds like tape them around
open them up the one that's going in
yeah shove five in there
that just feels that just sounds like
I'm playing with my foreskin
the same idea same idea same idea it's
like you're stuffing a four skip I have
that so I know I have that so I know so
it's definitely possible what's it like
uh having your foreskin still yeah
you're a fan of it did you wish it was a
five skin damn no I wish it was cut to
be honest really even now even now
not now but when you're growing up but
when I was growing up everyone's like yo
what the [__] is that I was like what
the [__] that's how I felt I begged my
parents to get surgery because I wanted
to be normal like the other boys I did
too but then I realized that it's
probably not a good idea well Elementary
like back in my days why is everyone
looking at your dick though well because
back in my days you know when you use
the restroom it was a it was one of
those tensions
I tell everybody this we all pee
together yes and then but no one
remembers this I remember right now yeah
you guys did it other people look at me
like you didn't do this as a kid no yeah
we all just trenches we all look well
you guys playing baseball today but uh
basketball and I was like yo why does
your look like that I don't know what
the [__] Minds look like this yeah it's
more like this you never had that where
it's like everyone everyone's like oh I
have to pee and like I had to pee too
and then you have like five boys going
into one stall
[__] surround and peeing together
someone can understand you you did that
too yeah
dude our brains were we weren't even
thinking like it's okay yeah
you guys are not out yeah yeah
no we just haven't came out not even
that what are you talking about we're
just like everything together hell yeah
let's go back to class you just wanted
to do everything together yeah yeah it's
just a homie [__] if we could [__]
together and like talk and hold hands
and like while we're all like if all
there was no doors right if boys could
just sit next to each other
and hold hands like this and found his
limit
I think we would have because pooping is
you time though right
well I didn't mind probably like staring
at each other pooping when we're younger
no like all in a group like this all
like holding hands like this one two
three and then squeeze together you
don't think so pinch them off all right
I would have done it
yeah great so five caterpillars huh
like we didn't pee together I thought
every
friends yeah
this one did Mark did too I did too yeah
you know none of my uh schools I
remember vividly like me and all my
friends for probably like maybe seven or
eight watching Baywatch and then like
sitting in my living room and they're
like oh I think my dick swollen what
about yours oh I think my dick's swollen
too this one like mine and we're like
squeeze each other's Disney is that
boners from watching like Baywatch and
[__] and we're like oh [__] I'm like oh
we should go pee because then we like
let's go pee with swollen dicks and then
we're all just missing out the back of
the toilet not even into the water yeah
because you did not control it yet yeah
because you're trying to force force it
and you're like oh [__] everyone's dicks
pointing upwards yeah yeah he's just
like what's happening when did you lose
your virginity
13. oh [__] was that like what's the
story and what was his name
her name
her so he he identified as a hero no it
was a her name was Jeffrey she
no it was just uh I forgot uh I don't
even know it was a smaller man you don't
know her name anymore
he's
he's taking it easy right now I'm saying
it was a check Filipino chick in Hawaii
everybody we did it in her dad's uh bed
wow dad's bed yeah her dad's bad oh
we're doing it and I was like whoa this
feels crazy I was like this is nice you
know but I didn't know how to act oh bro
oh brother this is called
slippery but it was cool that was my
first time yeah for the first time who
taught you to how'd you know what you
were doing it was natural oh if you
think about it like you guys are just
making out and then yeah yeah the first
time I uh I figured out about coming was
because my Grandpa would have been in
his room smoking cigarettes watching
porn with a vibrator
[Music]
oh he wasn't doing it publicly you
caught him yeah I caught him I thought
he was like in the living room just like
chilling no he was in his bed every day
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know anyone that smokes
cigarettes and jacks off at the same
time that is some gangster [__] what a
legend when we had cable I forgot what
channel it was like 999 or some old the
last channel is always porn
the last chance yeah but then for my
lady it's just like you know when you
rub kick on their butt you're like oh
yeah
is it time
is this what my friends were talking
about
that's when I was like let me oh that's
when I first found out are you more uh
are you more Sacramento are you more
Hawaii Hawaii baby all the way all the
way how old were you when you moved uh
from Hawaii 15. you went as your whole
family just well my whole family was me
and my uh my brother and my mom yeah
we're stuck in this one room at
someone's house why why did you guys
move to Saka Tomatoes uh I'm gonna be
honest with you my mom one day woke us
up from my Pastor's house this is when
we got evicted we got Pastor's house and
she's like packed your [__] and I was
like what the [__] going on just pack
your [__] we gotta go and I was like
what so she just grabbed us didn't tell
us where we were going she just drove us
to the airport
damn yeah and then we're in the plane
I'm in shorts jacket as soon as we land
Sacramento it's snowing I mean not
snowing but it was hailing no just you
and your brother me and my brother and
my mom oh my auntie's picking us up and
this is where we got to stay and I was
like yo mom if we're staying in [__]
Idaho or somewhere with cows and [__]
I'm piercing my whole ears and I'm
gauging it the whole time he's thinking
about piercing his ears where's that I
need permission
yeah because
[Music]
everyone is mine I just want to pierce
my ears and [__] Hawaii the Filipinos
were like gauge The Quest Crew hair
middle piercings
everyone had bands and stuff but so on
the way to um our home in Sacramento I
see cows
and I'm like Mom I told you if this is
where we stay I'm piercing my ears and
you got him piercing I gauged it in
Sacramento Sacramento
that's crazy were you like finally I
could be free I could be myself yeah but
just to realize the whole
in Sacramento looked whack yeah yeah
Sacramento was just like because I used
to you stand out yeah recognizable no
one knows what the hell it only works
during the summer because in the winter
you can't be too Hawaii swag you can't
that's why I was like whoa what is this
because it was a USC uh it was just like
a college sweatshirt with short pants
and vans that was a swag and I was like
yo what is this this is lame everyone
was dressed like that True Religions
Converse and I was like
dang I'm the minority in the school now
wow well they didn't look at you and be
like what's that that's so cool oh they
say you're from Hawaii did you serve hot
to hot and I was like holy cow that's
kind of a bloody
rooms are serious did you swim from do
you drink coconut
that's what kind of Asian are you and I
was like what kind of what is this I was
like Mom tattooing myself
[Laughter]
do anything
did everyone started wearing diamond
swag and I was like yo
what do I get these outfits
yeah did you ever talk to your dad about
why you bounced
uh nope because I knew from my cousin
but when he he called you no Facebook
how are you
how are you doing how are you
was this big Facebook picture like this
his Facebook business is a no user
assistant
oh yeah so he said are you taking care
of Mom I said who the [__] is this
oh [__] how are you
so what what did you find out from your
cousin oh so my cousin called me three
years ago
he said yo you know the reason your dad
left was because he got chipped by a
lawyer saying you're gonna get your
citizenship so I need about ten thousand
dollars and back then is a lot it's 2008
2007. yeah still out 2008 2007 that's
when the whole Market crashed too you
could have got citizenship for way less
than that yeah but my dad hopped over
Canada to Washington
where the [__] did you do that Dad how
did he end up in Hawaii he he flew
Washington to Hawaii yeah but the lawyer
said I could get you a citizenship for
10 G's but really because he knew his
situation because he came over illegally
you couldn't have gotten it but the
lawyer was playing him
wow so the lawyers took the money they
took the money and said peace out
that's the first time I ever seen my dad
cry on the phone to the bank yo give me
my money back you know look at my dad
like you [__]
why are you crying but I didn't know at
that time yeah damn holy [__] so why did
he go to Korea because he had nowhere
else to live where he couldn't face his
family all his money was gone yeah from
Hawaii so he had no choice and then the
market crashed everything was [__] yeah
business went down he had nothing left
so he wanted to go to Korea to make
money to come back to come back but
never could never how come how come he
didn't take the whole family with him I
don't know man that's what I'm saying yo
what the hell happened but I'm glad you
didn't
this life is better here it is weird
though I feel like a lot of Asian dads
the way they solve problems is by
themselves yeah it's not like we're a
unit so if I'm going through this
together the whole unit moves it's like
I gotta go solve this yeah and then I
think if you create a bigger problem
that thing I realized we had [__]
[__] shitty dance yeah no cause solid
Asian dads are they they know how to
solve [__] with their families like we
just had deadbeat dads yeah yeah he just
dipped that they didn't know how to
solve [__] in general
yeah like that's why because I see other
people's families and they don't [__]
they're not as stupid as our dads no
they're not I don't know but I did the
same [__] [__] all right that's Asian
you all should have been smarter
but we're they're like The Losers of
Asians like they're not they weren't the
[__] actual mover like our dads are
doctors and politicians and like top
level people you know what I mean like
they're like they didn't make it they
had a [__] you know what I mean like
they didn't yeah that's what happened
yeah I don't know that's just my take on
it because I'm like every all of us have
the same story with stupid ass problem
solvers they don't know how to [__]
solve [__] they're like they make up
stupid reasons you know it's like yeah
just running away
less less weight on them how does your
mom cope with like
raising you and and uh by yourself just
drinking just drinking no she knows she
would have to go work like what do you
call non-stop but she was always
figuring out how
like that's why we moved to Sacramento
because my mom was like yo can you get
us a job can uh to her best friend can
you get us a job and then we'll start
our life from there so we moved to
California Sacramento and then my auntie
gave her a job but my auntie's business
got broken into
so they had to file bankruptcy so my
mom's like damn we gotta go somewhere
else which her best friend was in L.A in
La you could get job anywhere
so my mom's uh moved to LA but we didn't
move to LA at that time so you guys
stayed in Sacramento he stayed in
Sacramento were you already older or
yeah I was already 16 17 but so you
stayed with like family friends I stay
with my homie that I was dancing with
their family which was Mexicans it was
cool staying with the Mexican families I
was like this was cool because the
Mexican family had a dad only a dad not
the mom
they were switching spots all the time I
was like this is cool at least they're
in the same area switching spots oh like
they're were they together or they're
just like working and then no just baby
daddy stuff oh okay okay but the Dow was
cool because he was Ty raised with
Mexicans whoa so the the time yeah what
the [__] it was America bro what the
[__] is going on my whole life was a
trip so my my homies down which I call
him dad till this day oh that's dumb
took me in
but he was he only knew a bunch of
Mexicans like ex nortaniels and all of
that so he's a Thai guy that
uh not married but had a kid with the
Mexican lady so your buddy was half Thai
half Mexican half Ty half Mexican and
then you stayed with their family the
mom at first and something crazy
happened and then I moved in with the
dad dad didn't want me at first because
I teased him about his toilet
[Laughter]
[__] you need a you need to clean that
[__] up you know
I think about I'm like damn that's
[__] up but was it really a shitty
toilet was it a broken toilet it was
just a toilet flood all the time I was
like was it dirty
you gotta snake that thing dude I can't
even take a [__] this is a problem and
he was like all right never insult a
man's Choice whatever I need to tease
somebody with and for them to be so mad
to be angry
toilet that's my toilet he was mad
because he was insecure he's like God
damn it yeah so my buddy came to me he's
like yo my dad don't like you because
you tease about it you tease his toilet
toilets
[Laughter]
how's your relationship with their dad
now
cool I guess I don't really I mean I
talk to him here and there but every
once in six months is that something
you're trying to repair no it's just
it's just the way it is or well now that
I heard the story I'm cool with him hey
Dad hey what are you doing cutting hair
that's what you're gonna do and then I
just leave it unrest don't tell me what
to do oh yeah I'm Gonna Leave It unread
but yeah that's funny I know like who's
here to tell you yeah I mean at this
point that's the crazy part I'm not
really close to my dad anymore I even
with my Grandma Grandpa died I didn't
really
there was no emotion yeah yeah it's what
I'm saying you didn't save your
grandpa's vibrator
that's why I bought one
wait your jack off Grandpa was his dad
uh my mom's dad okay but that you're
close to those grandparents traditional
life I I I was I was so they passed away
from butt cancer oh blood cancer you
should have played with his booty more
butt cancer that's what he calls that
anal cancer you could get butt cancer
damn that's crazy I didn't know that
yeah I don't know [__]
I didn't know [__] man wasn't dick
cancer though that's for sure just
growing up trying to survive you know
yeah because because really like jacking
off great he's very I would say super
Dependable just as a person yeah what
traits
do you want to have as a dad when you
have a kid like what's most important to
you when I have a kid yeah
it's culture just respect you know stuff
like that just I feel like if you just
teach them respect and culture a kid can
go far like the way you you make fun of
your friends dad's toilet yeah that's
why I'm teaching you cultures I'm gonna
be nice don't say some dumb stuff like
that but what's which culture are you
gonna Center more on because you're with
uh because his wife is Russian right
Russian Jewish Russian juice yeah so
what's the household gonna be more of
probably gonna be under her sick you're
gonna be Jewish you're gonna get
connected bro my kid is yeah
because I thought that like the Jewish
is connected through the mom so the mom
has to be Jewish to be
Jewish culture yeah but technically yeah
technically I can't still you still
can't I still I don't know what I gotta
do but if I do they probably gotta chop
off the oh
top to foreskin yeah and I mean but um
my kid is
hey my kid's gonna be so I'm gonna try
to send him to Jewish school and be like
be friends with all of them oh yeah yeah
you better get in the
so I can do my stunts yeah no so I can
just chill I'm on a yard I want a yard
and a dog my lady that's it
that's tight that's your future you want
to you watch your watch your lady Garden
while the dog runs around the birds
that's peaceful when the AR next to me
buddy
let's see
nah oh yeah
where do you want to also with the AR
they're not going to jail that huh you
can't have AR in Hawaii though right
yeah you can you can have all you can
have any guns you want ARX in Hawaii
yeah it's just harder to get it's harder
to get check in all the time with HPD oh
yeah yeah
who's got the hottest question Nick how
did you meet your wife
Instagram she hit me up first oh we're
supposed to just be you know what'd she
say what was her introduction can you
teach me how to break dance and I was
like I sure can
no no no it was supposed to be just this
we're supposed to be just this but you
know seven years in now and we're
married
it just happened she grew up here she
grew up here uh Ukraine Israel here wow
she's really cool she's she's a tattoo
artist yeah yeah in Hollywood yeah did
she do some work on you in my whole back
can I see show your back ending with
your back yeah dude dude
I didn't even know you had one on your
neck
wow
snake in a what tiger
a snake around a tiger that's a Royal
Rumble it's a snake tiger and uh
what is it
Dragon it's back there tiger and
what the [__] is that
it's like a griffin
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]